anstehen anstehen und nochmal an stehen
ja überall in deutschland gibt es ja
gerade das ganze das gleiche bild lange
schlangen vor den im stationen mein
vater stand jetzt am wochenende selbst
in einem kleinen dorf zwei stunden an um
seine booster impfung zu bekommen die
politik hat laut zum impfen getrommelt
ist aber wieder mal auf den ansturm
nicht vorbereitet unsere bild kollegen
waren unterwegs in deutschland und haben
sich angestellt
münchen 70 meter
stuttgart 100 meter berlin 80 meter
hamburg 300 meter
dortmund 80 meter
leipzig 200 meter
frankfurt 100 meter wesel 30 meter
duisburg 20 meter halle
250 meter
[Applaus]
jetzt haben wir das zu unserem reporter
eines rávic im berliner linden center wo
kurzfristig an ins zentrum aufgebaut war
und wie viel meter bahn sender hannes
na ja in den letzten tagen war die
schlange hier einmal um den block herum
da stand hier allerdings noch der imbus
daraufhin weil die zustände so chaotisch
waren wurde dann hier im innenraum
dieses centers ganz spontan vom
katastrophenschutz einen raum
bereitgestellt der eben den hygienischen
anforderungen genüge tut damit sie eben
ihnen geimpft werden kann es gab hier
eine szene von einer älteren dame die
über 80 jahre alt war die vier stunden
an stand um sich im bus impfen zu lassen
mussten zu lassen und eine dame war so
kalt dass sie also plötzlich ein
dringendes bedürfnis hatte sie hatte
aber so angst ihren platz auf zu geben
damit sie sich eben danach dann wieder
nicht hinten anstellen muss stand sind
da in größter not und all so dass eine
prekäre situation gewesen nicht nur für
sie sie ist aber sicherlich beispielhaft
gewesen für diese katastrophalen
bedingungen die eben hier in berlin
lichtenberg herrschen mittlerweile heute
ging es hier einigermaßen vor wenigen
minuten hat das impfzentrum hier
geschlossen in einem anderen impfzentrum
immer links center wenige kilometer von
hier entfernt stand der impfpass davor
heute auf einem gelände der deutschen
bahn plötzlich fühlte sich ein
bahnmitarbeiter aber gemütlich zu diesem
im fuß von seinem gelände von seinem
gelände von dem gelände der deutschen
bahn entfernen zu lassen da stand aber
schon eine 400 meter lange schlange
davor so dass die polizei gerufen wurde
die daneben versucht hat diese schlange
hinter dem bus in einem ordentlichen
zustand zum rathaus zu bewegen weil der
bus dann vor dem rathausplatz
aufgestellt worden war weil da dieser
wild gewordener mitarbeiter eben keinen
einfluss geltend machen konnte um diese
schlange daneben geordnete darüber zu
stellen und plötzlich ein tumult kommt
das also einer sagte gestanden doch vor
ihnen musste eben die polizei praktisch
diese impfwilligen schlange mit umziehen
völlig irre was da abging in diesem im
bus sind nur zwei ärzte die also etwa 20
eben für willige pro stunde abarbeiten
können und man kann sich vorstellen die
leute haben eben jetzt zur zeit den
druck dass sie zur arbeit gehen wollen
und dafür brauchen sie eben die impfung
die erste eben von wenigstens damit sie
eben als kämpft gelten und man habe
neben das bedürfnis und wie du sagst die
politik hat eben ist nicht geschafft
genug otto hierzu bereits johannes du
hast gerade ich wollte erst impfungen
hat man irgendeine schätzung oder einen
überblick wie viele sich denn jetzt erst
impfen lassen dort und wie viele sich
boostern lassen
das kann man natürlich nur schätzen weil
ich natürlich nicht mit allen leuten
reden gern und schon gar nicht an den
anderen standpunkten und jetzt wie
gesagt ist der laden hier zudem die im
zentrum haben die tore geschlossen um 18
uhr wir waren vorher schon gar zwei
stunden vorher wir hatten tatsächlich
einige leute gesprochen die zum ersten
mal jetzt kommen die gesagt haben naja
eigentlich wollte ich nicht es ist zwar
immer noch freiwillig aber ganz ehrlich
wenn ich keine lohnzahlung mehr bekommen
weil ich nicht geimpft bin dann ist es
mit der freiwilligkeit eben nicht mehr
so weit also ich denke schon dass einige
leute hier in prozent kann es nicht
ausdrücken aber doch schon hier sind die
sich eben wirklich zum ersten mal impfen
lassen vielen dank an dich handelt für
den reporter einsatz